you do all your own stunts huh didn't
you break everything yeah i just broke
both my arms uh like what movie was that
it's a movie called tag it's a sort of
action comedy sort of thing and and how
do you break both your arms in that
moment we fell like 20 feet off a stack
of chairs did you need to do that stunt
um you can see my face my body doing a
stunt yeah yeah so that's important to
you that's important that's like jackie
chan [ __ ] right i mean like he does all
his own stuff yeah yeah i suppose you
know it's just
you spend so much time and money to try
to create a world for people to go sit
down in the chair and watch a movie you
don't want him to like be pulled out of
a movie because you know see some
guy with a bad wig trying to do the
stunt but does a director ever say to
you listen we can get the coverage on
this thing like when you were making a
wind river that which we'll talk about
the new movie i saw this great movie
when you were making that movie you're
right you're driving around on a um like
one of those snow what do you call a
snowmobile
mobile you drove that snowmobile
yourself right yeah all of them except
for the big wide shots um because we
only had x amount of days to really kind
of uh
shoot this little independent movie so
and that's you are driving it around
except for earlier the big wide shots
and the guy really kind of getting after
it um otherwise but does the director
ever say you listen we need you in the
movie if you break your head i would
think it would would cancel the whole
movie yeah i just wouldn't do something
that where i would break my head and
elizabeth olsen who's in that movie with
you yeah she's on the back of this uh
snowmobile yeah and she's like yelling
at you to slow down because you're crazy
there's stuff there's stuff for uh not
crazy
i just know my limitations uh it's the
same like with rachel vice on born
legacy it's on that motorcycle it's like
you're on a on two wheels and slippy
road and you know you just got to be
careful because you are responsible for
somebody else's well-being you did those
stunts on boring legacy right yeah yeah
geez you're out of your mind it's just
it yeah you think you got a death wish
or something no not at all it's the only
time i ever got injured was in this
comedy
that stupid comedy
you mean
it's crazy
what do you do after you break both your
arms are you still gonna be able to work
yeah look i yeah i broke both of my arms
i got back up and i did the stunt again
get out of here oh my god on lunch i
went to the hospital i said yeah that's
broken that's broken and i went back to
work how do you how do you how many
weeks are you in cast from breaking bad
you uh it's supposed to be by like
around four to six weeks i think um but
i was in splints so i could um not have
the tendons and
ligaments everything kind of lock up and
let me ask you a question no one's
probably ever asked you if you make duty
and you have both arms broken yeah how
do you wipe your ass i got by did you
yeah you were able to do it i was able
to do it yeah the right the left wrist
was all right i was hanging in there no
kidding yeah but a lot of people thought
you know yeah what's he gonna do
yeah no that was my first thought
like i don't even know how you get
dressed if you have both arms broken
that i couldn't do you couldn't no
no no people have to dress you yeah
that's where you feel like oh my god i'm
90.
now you know people like my shoes
zipping up my fly oh my god bloody my
pants i'm like this is pathetic but i'd
still go out and go to work dude you're
something else 175 out cue you can zip
up your pants almost everything can take
a dump with both arms broken
incredible skills i'm going to put this
in my resume no i mean that it's pretty
awesome i'm very impressed with you
i know i'm really very impressed with
you